oh I guess I owe Marvel an apology the
original King of seizure-inducing studio
logos is New Line Cinema Jesus I need to
sit down
movie opens with some kind of
picture-in-picture bullsh image sighs
and I don't like it
credits font is one degree away from
Comic Sans let's see I can enter the
dreams of children and my first thought
for a weapon is finger knives discount
Jennifer Grey like I legitimately
thought this was Jennifer Grey for a
second why is this hallway soaking wet
was there a burst pipe or something yes
believe it or not there was a time in
this world when Johnny Depp needed
introducing ah goats wait I'm not scared
of goats movie unintentionally inspires
the finale de Terminator 2 Judgment Day
so what do you dream
forget it Tina the point is that
everyone has a bad dream once in a while
no she Nancy she asked what your dream
was not some condescending thing you
tell a four-year-old after a nightmare
[Applause]
Glen gets a sound effects tape from his
friend to fool his mom into thinking
he's staying at a place near the airport
but for a larious comic relief he
somehow doesn't know that car crashes
and women screaming are also on this
tape remember when I wouldn't tell you a
minute ago because I felt the need to
tell you how bad dreams work I think
this movie is actually set in
present-day 1980s but threats still come
at a 1950s style pace shrug and tackle
cliche Oh intense huh rod decides to
bring a gardening tool to the party he
crashes for pretty much zero reason
other than foreshadowing so what's going
on here an orgy or something maybe a
funeral dickhead without warning movie
suddenly turns into West Side Story
Tina allows rod to put his rod inside of
her also teen pregnancy that's the real
nightmare am i right I feel better now
right man fix Jay Tina was broken
because she's a woman I guess anyway man
penis solves all problems no more fights
no more fights
man I miss high school when you still
had some sort of belief that your
thoughts weren't delusions
Jesus is a dicta high school girls Fred
Krueger really wants to murder these
kids but sometimes in the dream world
colors are limited by physical walls
next time use the window Freddy
spooky an iconic image from Nightmare on
Elm Street franchise accidentally
inspires spooky an iconic balloon men
from car dealerships it's funny because
it's true
okay so rod isn't dreaming right now
this is real which means in the real
world people can levitate to the ceiling
also these peacocks are hideous rod is
wondering how his penis can fix this
yeah asshole people walking by somehow
didn't notice the kidnapping maneuver
that rod just pulled in broad daylight
jeez dude if you knew this guy you think
as a killer was gonna go after your
daughter what took you so long to go
back there and save her what the hell
were you doing going to school today for
anyway dad calm schools his daughter for
going to school when her going to school
was the basis for his entire operation
yep that pretty much explains it I know
Fred he likes to play around with his
victims but damn he doesn't have much
time and he keeps waiting so long that
he lets them get away lots of times I'm
sure maybe he's just a patient guy he
knows they have to sleep sometime and
he'll get them eventually but if I was
bent on getting revenge through kids
dreams I'd want to kill them as soon as
possible especially if they've already
escaped me twice Nancy's mom randomly
knocks on the door to give this out of
nowhere warning about sleep drowning
falling leaf ready once again probably
not approved by the FDA also name on the
label is extremely handy and telling
people exactly what the pills inside it
do I'm having horrible nightmares and my
best friend just got murdered by someone
in my dreams what stay awake watching
Evil Dead also this is 1984 and it looks
like she's only got UHF VHF TV with no
cable which network is playing the Evil
Dead at this hour she even has a book to
read who tries to stay awake reading
books who builds something on their
house that is basically a perfect ladder
street to their teenage daughter's room
also Glen randomly comes at the perfect
time to set up another scary scene
uh-huh I guess this is some sort of
in-joke because she is 20 years old but
no you don't come on 20 when you're 17
is 20 considered old
crazy favor to ask you if it doesn't
involve sex I don't care nothing Julie
I'm guessing there's a scene that was
cut or not filmed where Nancy saw Tina
get zipped up in a body bag and that's
why she keeps streaming of it the scary
part is not that she's dead and visiting
Nancy and her dreams the scary part is
that all this is rods actual unborn baby
so we all dodged a bullet there ah Fred
you were just inches away from killing
her for the fourth time in this movie
and you went made two big rookie
mistakes dream garbage can slow Freddy
down in a world where he creates the
rules
Nancy dreams in film continuity errors
window did not have a crack at it before
but does now so that it can be easily
smashed hey dreams are tough out there
in the hood why would this dream set up
booby traps tears but once she got to
the second floor allow her to run
without a problem
damn Fred you've only successfully
killed one person in this movie so far
you might want to tone down the
wisecracks and jump scares and get on
with the killing a little faster next
time also how can Freddy slice people up
in the dream world and the results show
up in the real world but other stuff he
does like smashing through doors and
slashing pillows totally doesn't carry
over to the real world
remember he sliced Tina's nightgown
earlier and it showed up in the real
world so it's not just the physical body
that's affected fast
Nancy calls Glen a bastard for failing
his guard duties but first of all he
didn't come to your room in the middle
of the night to watch you sleep second
if you have promised him at least a boob
flash for doing this job he might have
been more alert single pillow feathers
suggest that maybe the pillow did get
sliced after all but pillow is intact so
I'm confused
Ron sleeps in his leather jacket because
those things are super comfortable when
sleeping in jail also this is spooky and
all but why does pretty bother to hang
the guy does he think that if he used
his finger knives that these cops would
crack the case and start doing sleep
studies to catch him in the dream world
furthermore what is Ron dreaming about
so that Freddy can do this to him this
killing is all too sneaky for what we've
seen in this movie so far did the police
really consider this case unsolved I
mean yeah we know there's a guy killing
kids and dreams but they don't and it
would be a pretty open-and-shut case
without that knowledge because rod is a
nice sort of guy with priors also this
murder is sneaky but it's also the
slowest murder since the horribly slow
murderer with extremely inefficient
weapon
why would Nike agree to this kind of
product placement hey guys I'm gonna get
those shoes that asshole rod wore during
a violent hanging scene cool huh more
than three people show up to Ron's
funeral also we didn't even get to see
Tina's funeral I only knew about rod was
that he was a dick and he gets a whole
funeral scene
slice
and his death attest to the scriptures
warning but he who lives by the sword
shall die buns damn that's some bullshit
to be saying it at funeral these people
actually like rod for some reason so
dick move from the priest there rather
than show you Freddy Krueger once again
failing at killing Nancy movie has a
swatch Barbra Jean and the future voice
of Roger Rabbit watching Nancy sleep
pretties allowing kids to steal his hat
what kind of psycho killer is this what
you're trying to learn the dream clinic
is your refrigerator running time to get
a teenager to hold it back wanton
destruction of delicious booze somebody
forgot to sign a search warrant in the
right place and Krueger was free just
like that oh come on
doesn't the signature itself constitute
a more or less proper search warrant why
not just say that someone forgot the
search warrant it would have been more
believable than this signature in the
wrong police technicality letting a
child murderer loose we didn't realize
was the burning child murderers sent
them into dominion over the dream world
and it would take 15 years for him to
return and kill their kids in their
sleep I knew we shouldn't have invited
that coven of witches to tag along but
we were real liberal back then because
mommy killed him and dozens of other
parents but I'm brave enough to take
credit Glenn's room is an orgy of
evidence that he's into nearly every
damn thing there is to be into also Nike
socks
damn girl you won't even sleep with your
boyfriend normal style and you're
proposing a threesome are you crazy I
don't know I never really thought this
through but what I do know is all jocks
have baseball bats that's for sure and
you've got a bottle of stay a week here
another one in the background and a huge
pot of coffee on the TV movie encourages
addictive lifestyles a hidden coffee pot
might be one of the first signs that you
have a problem
seriously I could recut this whole movie
into an after-school special if I needed
to and include the moms drinking r-rated
movie teases the fuck out of us for no
damn reason also I guess when you're
hunting psycho killers better dressed to
impress
Glenn's creeping father doesn't approve
of Nancy but apparently is a big fan of
the show she just put on in her bedroom
I don't care what you say I don't want
that kid anything you say a creeper
alcoholic father who was just introduced
to his 10 seconds ago I would send this
for the convenience a Nancy opens her
door just as Nancy's mom happens to be
pulling out yet another bottle of
alcohol
but I get the feeling that 95% of
Nancy's mom's time is spent finding
secret alcohol stashes and exploiting
them Glenn's balls turn into a mini TV
also Glenn felt the need to label his
headphones with his name you know just
in case in 1984 he was wearing them at
school listening to his ipod and left
them somewhere these kids that's all
let's go as a matter of fact Glenn's dad
just wandered into this picture a minute
ago and suddenly becomes the movie's
plot Lord so this guy could travel
through the phone lines now our phone
lines and the dream world connected
somehow she's definitely not dreaming at
least I don't think she is the stupid
ending that makes us reconsider the
entire last 20 minutes of this movie
hasn't happened yet
what are you the narrator but Glenn's
dad just went overboard yep his name is
Glenn but I do enjoy worrying about
people by calling out their direct
relationship to me oh no my brother oh
no my boss oh no my barbershop quartet
Jesus finally that blood from the
shining just can't find the right door
can it mom screaming her lungs out does
not attract the attention of Glenn's dad
who was so important five minutes ago
how does Glenn's dad not know about the
blood bath upstairs was the outside
drinking beer and looking in windows
this whole time without a clue in the
world
just come here exactly 20 minutes Nancy
knows exactly the length of time it will
take her to go to sleep
fight Freddy Kreuger and bring him out
into the real world you know what that
80s synth music means right time for a
montage I think it's safe to say for
this scene alone the entire home alone
franchise is indebted to Nightmare on
Elm Street also apparently reading a
book on booby traps makes you an expert
on making booby traps also Nancy told
her dad to break down the door in 20
minutes these tasks alone would take 20
minutes or more
Nancy's mom's pillows aren't piles of
liquor bottles oops spoke too soon
[Music]
Lord's Prayer cliche last four words of
the Lord's Prayer inspire way we were
stressed Craven movie 26 years later
okay let's see in 20 minutes Glenn died
the entire city went to Glenn's house
and Nancy strung up an entire books
worth of booby traps it should be about
2:00 or 3:00 a.m. right now but I'll
just go with it
did the composer of this film try to
emulate the ending of the song Dream
Weaver because if he did that's awesome
and sinful all at once
freddy is a big believer in 7th time's
the charm
now we know why it was so helpful the
Glen labeled his headphones I don't know
how you managed to dream and be alert to
arrest a psycho killer but I guess you
can just teach yourself lucid dreaming
after several pots of coffee and copious
bottles of stay awake what are you
waiting for asshole Freddy who we have
seen appear in one place and out of
nowhere in the next is contained by
simple doors when the plot requires
noticeable crack in window to help
people smash through it is noticeable
again define slow because you're already
there for me good god this is Nancy's
mom's room how did it not blow up as
soon as Freddie ran inside
door shuts for no damn reason other than
to provide jump scares for assholes you
remember how you killed the three other
people in this movie you didn't say
anything you just did it you're nothing
what worked seriously you weren't saying
things the power was inside you oh yeah
I'm gonna stop drinking I just don't
feel like it anymore dream is giving
obvious clues to Nancy that this is a
dream horror movie wants to have the
gotcha ending but it basically renders
the previous scene and everything we sat
through entirely moot
why did Freddy disappear after Nancy
told him to fuck off if he had this kind
of power he should have succeeded a lot
sooner than this and this motherfucker
is multitasking plus we already saw her
die once but maybe that was just Nancy's
dream so is this Nancy's mom's dream now
I have no clue what happened in this
movie
[Music]
I can't feel my legs Kizer yeah this is
real life
[Music]
it's like I picked the wrong week with
amphetamines your mother sucks cocks in
hell yeah give me the key mother I'm the
gatekeeper are you the keymaster say you
know I know I should have made a left
turn at Albuquerque
[Music]
[Applause]
you know if these kids in this movie had
eat more healthy and energizing snacks
maybe they wouldn't be falling asleep on
the door maybe snacks or Freddy
Krueger's true enemy
regardless naturebox want you to try
their five most popular snacks for free
yes free
[Music]
now go to naturebox.com/tyler box sent
to your door free snacks 5 I'm honestly
not sure how you're still watching this
video but since you are let me repeat
the opportunity in front of you you face
stuffed with deliciousness because you
watched a video and went to a website
it's that freaking easy you're welcome
and probably also be decreasing your
chances of falling asleep too much and
facing off with Freddy Krueger by like 5
percent or something again you're
welcome
naturebox calm down and don't look back